[Music]
what's your favorite part about married
life well it's being married to him you
know that's the truth yeah I really love
this dude and he's a chef right I have a
partner and I really feel that nice Amy
Schumer is off the market and she can't
stop gushing over her husband Chris
Fischer while promoting her new film
I feel pretty that's me yes you feel
different
yeah I do feel different I feel I'm done
I don't know if I have to zip my knee
boots up and leave some dudes plates at
4:00 a.m. as like a Rottweiler you know
that's actually the last member I have
her I was like just walking out
beforehand you might want to depose them
I don't know you know sneak peek means
you're completely all of us single girls
and the struggle did you know I know I
mean I was just there so I I can't be
like look let me tell you what it's like
I mean I was just there and I've tried I
really tried to make it work with people
that weren't right and I just knew I
didn't want to settle and I was like
I'll be fine on my own maybe I'll fall
in love a couple more times but I don't
need that partner and then I met the
person I wanted to partner up with and
and I I didn't know right away I I knew
him for seven months before we before it
became romantic but but once I knew I
knew quick I was like oh I'm done I
can't believe I messed with those other
suckers are you guys good or do you want
to expand your family oh uh I think when
we're ready we'd be really lucky to have
have a family you know
[Music]